[Applaudissements]
regarde
je prie les bras de mon ami regarde ici
et ici il y en a des milliers
regarde une étoile filante firent veut
vite
j'avais 7 ans et à l'époque je vivais en
afrique avec la famille de ma meilleure
amie
nous avions passé les vacances près de
la mauritanie là où le désert offres les
plus belles nuits étoilées que je n'ai
jamais vu et cette nuit là j'ai ressenti
une émotion très forte une émotion
difficile à décrire une émotion mêlée
d'une sensation de magie une sensation
de joie d'apaisement de curiosité oui de
curiosité parce que voyez j'avais le
désir de comprendre ce qui était en
train de se passer devant mes yeux cette
expérience c'est en fait de
l'émerveillement et cette émotion a
véritablement fait façonné ma vie
lorsque vous voyez à 7 ans lorsque j'ai
vu cette étoile filante
j'ai fait le voeu secret que quand je
serai grande je serai astronautes et je
voyagerai vers les étoiles
mais voyez je suis là ce soir
aujourd'hui pour vous faire partager un
peu se boude et d'émerveillement que
j'ai c'est quand la dernière fois que
vous vous avez ressenti ce sentiment
d'émerveillement
c'est quand réfléchissez
pour moi c'était il ya juste une seconde
parce que à chaque fois que je parle des
étoiles à chaque fois que je me remémore
ces instants dans le désert j'en ai la
chair de poule et ce soir eh bien j'ai
envie de vous faire partager un peu de
tout ça j'aimerais faire ça on vous
racontant des choses sur une étoile
fascinante qui j'espère va pouvoir
changer un peu votre quotidien
j'aimerais faire ça en vous racontant
que je ne suis pas devenir astronaute
du moins pas encore mais que je voyage
comme un vers les étoiles
et comment j'essaye d'apporter le
maximum de personnes avec moi
les étoiles si jamais la tous maintenant
on sortait on enverrait plein mais il y
en a une merveilleuse qui n'apparaît pas
dans le ciel nocturne forcément parce
que cette étoile c'est le soleil alors
la chose assez marrante à propos du
soleil c'est que on connaît tous il est
omniprésent il est là tout le temps même
quand il fait gris il est là au dessus
de noni débrayage a dû à briller de
mille feux
et pourtant on a tendance à oublier que
et bien le soleil il est aussi source de
vie les plantes vertes que nous mangeons
et bien elles se nourrissent de
l'énergie solaire pour exister
et si nous étions trop loin du soleil
aussi le soleil n'existait pas et bien
l'eau liquide n'existerait pas elle
n'existerait que sous forme de glace et
une image du soleil vu en lumière
visible
c'est à dire la lumière que nous a trop
humain ne pouvons capter avec nos yeux
cette image a été prise il ya seulement
quelques jours et vous voyez une sphère
jaune une une image puissante je dirais
image un peu apaisante une image très
familière en fait ce que vous voyez là
c'est seulement la surface du soleil et
au dessus de cette surface il ya une
atmosphère une atmosphère que nous nous
ne pouvons pas voir avec nos yeux
d'une part parce que eh bien
l'atmosphère à l'aimer en rayons
ultraviolets et ses rayons est révélée
sont en partie absorbée par l'atmosphère
terrestre et nous en tant qu'espèce et
bien on ne s'est pas développée pour
pouvoir voir ses rayons ultraviolets
alors on envoie des télescopes dans
l'espace et c'était les scop révèle la
splendeur de l'atmosphère du soleil -
vraiment quand je regarde cette
atmosphère et que je la vois bouger je
me dis mais pourquoi l'atmosphère du
soleil est elle aussi chaude
pourquoi est ce qu elle est aussi active
pourquoi est ce qu'elle est aussi
complexe
quand je vois les détails de cette
atmosphère et que je vois ce genre de
l'image je me dis qu'est-ce qu'il pleut
sur le soleil et bien la réponse est oui
ce que vous voyez là c'est un phénomène
d'instabilité de l'atmosphère du soleil
et on appelle ça de la pluie coronale ou
la couronne c'est la couche la plus
chaude de l'atmosphère du soleil
alors la prochaine fois que vous ouvrez
votre parapluie sans doute demain vous
dirais que même sur le soleil on peut
chanter sous la pluie avant que je
n'étudie le soleil je n'avais pas
réalisé à quel point vivre dans le
voisinage d'une étoile n'est pas de tout
repos
parce que même si nous ne sommes à plus
de 150 millions de km de notre soleil
150 millions de km et bien en fait on
baigne tout le temps dans un écoulement
de particules qui nous provient du
soleil dans les images que vous voyez
les flashs lumineux sont des éruptions
solaires et ses éruptions solaires sont
les événements énergétiques les plus
intenses de notre système solaire
lorsque ces éruptions solaires ont lieu
eh bien elle dissipe de l'énergie de
l'énergie équivalente à plus de milliers
de bombes thermonucléaires en quelques
minutes seulement
elle envoie dans l'espace des particules
énergétiques et parfois même des gros
nuages magnétisé qu'on appelle des
tempêtes solaires et ses tempêtes
solaires à peu se propager en direction
des planètes de notre système solaire
vous dites mais nous on est sur terre ce
qui se passe dans l'espace ça nous
touche pas trop et ben en fait si parce
que vous voyez les tempêtes solaires
elles peuvent être à l'origine de
dysfonctionnements sur nos satellites de
télécommunications de dysfonctionnements
sur nos satellites de navigation comme
par exemple le système gps et aussi les
dysfonctionnements sur nos réseaux
électriques
sur cette image vous pourriez l'europe
vue de l'espace
la nuit et je pense qu'on peut voir très
clairement notre dépendance à l'énergie
imaginez que toutes ces lumières
disparaissent en quelques minutes
dû à une éruption solaire un peu
préoccupé renom une autre histoire
il ya quelques mois une éruption solaire
a été à l'origine d'un blackout radio
sur terre un haka de radio qui a lieu
malheureusement en même temps où on
avait besoin de ces communications radio
pour pouvoir joindre les populations les
plus touchées par l'ouragan y remet à
dans les caraïbes
voyez on se rend de plus en plus compte
que finalement l'activité de notre
soleil impact énormément nos sociétés
humaines
moi en tant que physicien du soleil et
bien j'essaye véritablement de
comprendre ce qu'il se passe lors de ces
éruptions solaires de comprendre la
naissance de ces éruptions
j'utilise des images comme celles que
l'on vienne devoirs mais aussi des
données qui nous parviennent de sonde
spatiale que là on a envoyé à travers le
système solaire et en utilisant tout ce
jeu de données et bien j'essaye de
comprendre comment ces tempêtes naissent
dans l'atmosphère du soleil vont se
propager dans l'espace et impacter les
planètes avec toujours en tête que comme
la météo sur terre nos pulsions un jour
pouvoir les prédire et finalement ce que
je fais ce n'est pas seulement que de
regarder le soleil et les planètes du
système solaire
mes recherches me pousse également à
poser des questions dans d'autres
domaines de l'astrophysique lorsque
chaque nuit inlassablement nos
télescopes pointe vers les étoiles
eh bien on se pose la question de savoir
qu'est ce que ça veut dire de vivre dans
le voisinage d'une autre étoile à ce que
ses autres étoiles sont aussi active que
le soleil à l'heure où l'on découvre de
plus en plus d'exoplanètes
on se pose la question de savoir s'il
fait bon vivre
finalement en dehors du soleil alors
vous voyez même si j'ai les pieds ancrés
sur terre dans ma tête elle voyage quand
même vers les étoiles et c'était
merveilleux ans que j'avais quand
j'avais 7 ans eh bien je l' ai toujours
quand je pense à ces étoiles mais je lis
aussi notamment lorsque
eh bien j'ai ces données solaire ces
données spatiales qui me parviennent sur
l'ordinateur
alors ça peut vous paraître complètement
loufoque mais c'est vrai que j'ai ce
sentiment que je regarde une portion de
l'univers lorsque j'ai des données qui
me parviennent sur mon ordinateur parce
que c'est un peu comme si je suis en
train là de regarder un bon l'univers
qui a été collecté par un robot que nous
êtres humains on a lancé dans l'espace
enfin moi ça m'a complètement dingue et
j'aurais jamais cru quand j'avais 7 ans
que des années plus tard je serai moi
même en train de travailler sur une
mission spatiale seul arbitres heures
que vous voyez ici une mission de
l'agencé spatiale européenne qui va
démarrer dans quelques années et qui va
se rapprocher du voisinage du soleil
l'émerveillement l'émerveillement
finalement il a toujours été là
l'émerveillement
il a pas vu les développements de
l'humanité sont ses thèmes événements on
n'aurait jamais regardé à l'intérieur de
notre corps cette machine fantastique on
n'aurait jamais essayé d'imaginer ce qui
se passe dedans développer la médecine
comprendre la dn 100 émerveillement on
se serait sans doute jamais posé la
question de comment vole les oiseaux et
de cette manière construit nous avions
bien sûr on ne peut pas séparer
l'émerveillement de tous les
développements de l'humanité et moi-même
maintes et maintes fois je me suis
demandé comment est ce que je peux
apporter cet émerveillement au public
comment est-ce que alors que nous tous
on vit de plus en plus dans des villes
il est de plus en plus difficile de
regarder en ciel étoilé comment est ce
que je peux vous faire partager cet
émerveillement
comment est ce que je peux prendre le
bras de mes amis et leur dire regarde
ici et ici il y a des milliers des
toiles la réponse elle m'est arrivé il
ya quelques années lorsque la
technologie de la réalité virtuelle et
de la réalité augmentée ont investi nos
foyers et quand je vois ce que
maintenant le smartphone pas faire je me
suis dit
pourquoi pas alors avec un cinéaste très
peu d'argent est très peu de sommeil
on s'est lancé le défi de faire une
vidéo
en réalité virtuelle et d'emmener sur
notre navette spatiale tout le public
pour les faire voyager de la terre
jusqu'au soleil vous savez quoi les
résultats qu'on a eus ont été facilement
où que l'on aille dans les écoles dans
les festivals de science les ados les
adultes les enfants de 9 5 ans tous tous
ont adoré être dans l'espace et nous ont
montré ce que nous savions déjà que
l'émerveillement n'a pas de sexe
l'émerveillement n'a pas de couleur et
n'a pas d'âge alors on pense que la
technologie
c'est une affaire de riches une affaire
de privilégier une envie une révolution
digitale qui affecte le monde entier nos
smartphones deviennent nos ordinateurs
principaux dans les pays émergents
presque la moitié de la population en a
et on pense sans aucun doute que dans
les années futures
le premier accès à internet se fera par
des smartphones imaginez ce que l'on
peut faire avec ses bijoux de
technologie que l'on a dans le temps
dans nos poches imaginez que l'on puisse
utiliser la réalité virtuelle et la
réalité augmentée comme des vecteurs
d'émerveillement ce qui a commencé comme
une idée que j'ai partagée avec mon ami
cinéaste est devenu un de mes plus
grands défis le partage de mon
émerveillement
alors ce soir je suis ici avec vous pour
faire un petit bout de mon voyage
est ce que j'aimerais vous faire passer
comme message c'est que c'est quoi votre
émerveillement à vous c'est quoi ce qui
vaut des merveilles au plus profond de
vous pour moi c'est clairement les
étoiles mais pour vous qu'est ce que
c'est et quand vous avez trouvé ça
comment les faire partager avec le monde
entier
je n'ai pas fini astronautes mais peu
m'importe
que j'en ai bien plus appris sur les
étoiles avec le métier que je fais
aujourd'hui
et si en plus je peux inspirer les
générations futures
si je peux les émerveiller si je peux
les aider à regarder en ciel étoilé ou à
regarder de l'avant
alors c'est bien mais alors bien plus
que ce que je n'avais imaginé ce que je
n'avais souhaiter à 7 ans cette étoile
filante près du désert de mauritanie
merci
[Applaudissements]